le pida un favor que yo soy su abuelita
Fátima usted me entiende tiene que estar
quieta porque ellos le están a buscar 18
días en vilo y un país aún a la espera
de un milagro las fuerzas militares de
Colombia continúan la búsqueda de cuatro
niños indígenas huitoto desaparecidos
desde el 1 de Mayo la pequeña avioneta
de pasajeros en la que viajaban se
estrelló en plena selva amazónica en el
sur del país ante la confusión mediática
en la que se anunció que los menores
habían sido encontrados con vida los
familiares exigieron respeto la salud
física y emocional no es un juego que
pueda ser borrado o fácilmente olvidado
la persecución de los medios de
comunicación para dar declaraciones no
solo desconoce nuestros derechos sino
que violenta y Aviva el dolor víctima de
dicha confusión fue el propio presidente
de Colombia Gustavo Petro quien tuvo que
rectificar su mensaje inicial admitiendo
que el hallazgo de los niños de 13 94
años y un bebé de 11 meses aún no ha
sido confirmado
He decidido Borrar el tweet porque no ha
sido posible confirmar la información
facilitada por el icbf Lamento lo
sucedido las fuerzas militares y las
comunidades indígenas continuarán su
inquieta búsqueda para que podamos
entregarle al país la noticia que está
esperando en este momento no hay otra
prioridad que seguir adelante hasta
encontrarlos la vida de los niños es lo
más importante fueron los mismos
miembros de la comunidad indígena
quienes dieron con el paradero de la
avioneta siniestrada la comunidad
aprovechó la coyuntura mediática para
denunciar las precarias condiciones de
seguridad de las pistas de aterrizaje en
esas áreas remotas de la amazonía la
operación Esperanza como bautizaron a la
misión de rescate si en curso